nous sommes dans l'un des vingt trois
ruches et bordé d'acacia de cet
apiculteur il y a dix ans me gilbert
gruss était un autodidacte munis de cinq
ruches désormais il en possède six ans
cet apiculteur aguerris n'a pas pu
empêcher que ces abeilles boivent la
tasse
à une chute de la production qui est de
70 % cette année et il va nous falloir 3
3 à 4 ans pour reconstituer nos stocks
pour s'en remettre à la chute de la
production en l'expliquent pas dû à la
météo kate est catastrophique humide et
très froides on a eu une année très
froide malgré la baisse de la production
il faudra comprimer les prix et pour
cause et prix malheureusement nous
allons pas pouvoir les augmenter les
consommateurs ici on augmente notre prix
de 2,3 euros kg ils vont pas pouvoir
l'accepter et le miel est déjà assez
cher c'est quand même un produit de luxe
et on va garder nos tarifs et on va
essayer de reconstituer nos stocks dans
les trois quatre années à venir de
retour à la miellerie une odeur sucrée
flotte dans l'air les pains d'épicés
sortent du four il faut vite les
emballer afin qu'ils conservent tout
leur mois et le daim et pis donc il est
fait ici sur place à la confiserie avec
notre miel principalement du miel de
forêt pour qu'ils aient plus de goût
plus de saveur on fait plusieurs sortes
de pâtisseries
la boutique et les produits dérivés
maison c'est le domaine de nancy vers
creuse un projet né dans la douleur du
premier confinement la vente directe
affiche désormais une santé rayonnante
la france consomme 40 mille tonnes de
miel par an pour une production de dix
mille tonnes les importations pourrait
bondir ce qui risque bien de donner un
goût amer au miel tricolore